we're gonna make a division then we're
going to make a statement on the base
set division to connect the dividend
defines a quotient and remainder okay so
let's do the division first there are my
two bits the Pala know you're going to
divide by which is really the dividend
this is what I'm dividing by the divisor
so that's why I call it D watch end up
with often is called P for polynomials
so and they said in have two things that
are going towards deeper dividend and
divisor so let's get the appointments
now firstly coefficients of the actual
polynomial to negative one zero because
there are no x squared terms negative
three and negative five what about
negatives in that and then I want the
zero of the divisor the zero of this guy
which is two okay so I'm ready to go to
go I need my first step which is just
going to beat you to write down the give
your name what's it called the leading
coefficient remember we said things get
names and for sometimes I can use I keep
talking about this number be great if I
had a special name what does have a
special me write someone write down the
leading coefficient and then he comes by
repeating step by multiplying and adding
multiply everybody ready
wait can you miss it okay multiply add
multiply add multiply add multiply add
seriously like I'm still I'm still
writing down the question if I'm doing
this by the long division okay just
because it takes me so long to write
down the X isn't what happened okay so
there's the coefficients of what I need
always dividing degree four by degree
one so I should end up with degree 3
okay so this is 2x cubed plus 3x squared
plus 6x plus 9 with the remainder of 13
so this sum is concluded this summary
step I'm going to make
I have pictured it before it's what we
call the division transformation
statement I'll write that down the
division transformation line
okay and I've written it down a couple
of times I just haven't stayed in today
so it's say the original polynomial is
divisor times quotient plus your main
time let's do that again
divisor times quotient plus okay how
does it look hey happy again I can very
quickly confirm that I did it right
because when you have a look at the only
constant term you're going to get out of
this right it's going to be negative 2
times 9 which is negative 18 and then I
have 13 which gives me the negative 5
I'm supposed to get okay so what I'm
going to do from this is I can make a
general statement right for not just
this particular dividend and this
particular divisor I can say look any
polynomial I can express it in this
division transformation way right
divisor times question plus remainder
I'm interested in these divisors in
particular right now what you have a
look at this percentage if I take this
guy because of the way I factorize that
little chunk at the beginning then watch
what happens if I substitute in the
value a right let X equal a and then see
what unfolds okay because of the way I
factorize this first bin you end up
getting a take away a right do you see
that like I've just substituted it a x'
everywhere I see excellent there were
just two spots right you notice that so
being that I've got a take away a at the
start there what happens to that first
for the expansion
it just becomes zero right it disappears
in fact all you get left with is the
remainder right arm
P
a equals ah you know what it's like what
what is the remainder often I've divided
right so here's my statement and this is
a theorem because it's so important
in other words pea baby if you put in a
if you substitute into your regional
polynomial right that's the remainder if
you divide by X minus a right if I
divide by X minus 2 then if I were to go
back to this original polynomial and
saying what's P up to okay
let's actually just crunch this out I'm
going to 2 times 16 minus 8 minus 6
minus 5 that's 32 takeaway that's minus
40 minus minus 19 which is 13 right
which is the remainder that I got before
always bitter leaf my mental arithmetic
works okay so you can see if what I
really wanted to know is the radar and
you should why I want to do that in a
second then I turned out to go through
this whole division synthetic spots but
still it's the time consuming right if
what I really want is they're made up I
could go straight there directly like
this and I can do it because of the
debated transformation and putting in
that value a for example put in that
value 2 is gonna make this part all
collapse you see that it all just
disappears because this part becomes 2
minus 2 which is here I don't care what
this number is gonna end up being I'll
just end up if that seems the remainder
okay so this guy here what we've just
written out this is called because it's
all about their maker this is called the
remainder theorem okay it's a fear of of
how to find iterative quickly other part
of you but then what immediately follows
on that is well the most important
remainder I'm offside is to actually
factorize something when I don't have
were made up but there is no remainder
or when the remainder is zero right if
the remainder is zero that you've got
this scenario for beta zero right in
other words you don't have some guy
hanging off the end you've got a perfect
factorization everything sits nicely
okay so if the remainder is zero then X
minus s not just some random divisor
it's a factor of the actual polynomial
side okay if you can divide through and
successfully get narrator then you have
a factor and that's why this last bit
here because it's not just about raiders
it's enough factors it's called a factor
theorem okay so there are made of
through the factor theorem are really
just well this is a special case of this
guy right the factor theorem is the
remainder theorem when there is it or
Aveda whether or maybe you end up with
is zero